I want to be inspired or challenged or
whatever I watch really yeah yeah the
things that you've done you know cus
D'Amato and and how like you bad
Mohammed leaving your key like all these
different things I was in doing for
school yeah I know your whole thing I
mean but yeah as a black man watching
the thing that you've done if they did
you've been through your ups and your
downs you know you can learn from that
your whole art I'm Evan Britt and I'm
Mike Tyson I'm like he's got a really
awesome guest here yeah he's cool I was
watching show I watch out jay-z and I
was really interesting yeah you know
what happened one of my favorite guys
from CNN Van Jones welcome to the
podcast
know the hottest podcast in the history
of the podcast I'm glad well just to
further introduce you you are the CEO of
the reformed Alliance the reformed
Alliance is committed to advancing
criminal justice reform and eradicating
laws and policies that perpetuate
injustice in the US to achieve that
objective the reform Alliance will
strive to pass probation bills at the
state level use media to amplify the
need for comprehensive reform and build
an inclusive bipartisan alliance of
leaders from business entertainment
sports and community industries who
share a cohesive vision for ambitiously
and efficiently transforming the
criminal justice system that's it it's
pretty awesome yeah well you know this
is something I've been focusing on for
about 25 years I graduated from Yale Law
School in 1993 and the year before that
was Rodney King 92 Wow and the year
after that was 94 Clinton crime bill and
so I'm a 24 year old black 24 year old
black kid with a Yale Law degree and
dreadlocks down my back and I was like I
feel like I'm under the tar
I feel like I feel like police brutality
and and this this prison thing is aimed
at me and both political parties were in
favor of building more prisons it was a
Bill Clinton crime bill California
passed three strikes in your house
California blue California built twenty
prisons and only one University over the
course of about 25 years somebody was
getting paid exactly yeah it's no doubt
about yeah and so I was like look we're
debate I mean we're we're we're just
gonna be you know the the Grist in the
mill I want to fight back so I use my
law degree in Oakland to try to fight
back
and I had to fight Democrats and
Republicans because both parties were
against us and now finally 25 years
later both parties are coming around you
got people like you know jay-z and
Robert Smith and meek Mill he's you know
big big vehicle coming around and I said
I wanted to put my 25 years to use hmm
well I think it's you're right on time
ya know it's crazy it is crazy so take
me back because as you say you've been
an activist for criminal justice reform
for a long time in Oakland you
co-founded the Ella Baker Center for
Human Rights Ella Baker Ella Baker is
one of the great unsung civil rights
heroines you know she when dr. King was
a young you know guy coming on the scene
created the SCLC Southern Christian
Leadership Conference he hired her to
run it because she was brilliant
organized she's been in double ACP she'd
been in labor she's a genius for
organizing but these young black
preachers was like you know she's like
the black grandma I just you'll do what
we say
she said what so she quit working for
dr. King and that later that year
the student started sitting in
spontaneously and she said they need
organization she said I'm gonna build a
a movement I want leaders that are
movement centered leaders I don't want a
leader centric movement she said dr.
King's trying to build a leader centric
movement I wanna move men Senate leaders
so she interposed herself between the
students and dr. King she said dr. King
do you need to do what you're doing I'm
help these students so the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee they
did all that voter registration all
sorts
those were her young people nobody knows
her name so I wanted to give her some
critically a lot of time black women are
the secret sauce they never get the name
on the label so we made the Ella Baker
Center for Human Rights you guys did a
lot of super important work there
tell me about Maurice Hudson yeah you
know just recently in Philadelphia you
know of course Meek Mill you know you
kind of yeah I got famously gotten sent
to prison prison that's supposed to be
for four years luckily we got about
because he was on probation and he
popped a wheelie he thought like you
didn't like you shoot nobody he didn't
rob a bank he just put on probation
popped a wheelie put it on Instagram
boom four years in prison so that
started a whole fight in Philadelphia
that probation is being abused probation
is being misused people are going back
to prison for nine crimes
it's a spider's web of probation I have
this written a club in Ohio I couldn't
hang around to pucker Bobby Brown stay
away you violated yeah Wow
I mean so going back to your telling you
who you can hang out this is my partner
at the time yeah I can't hang out with
Bobby Brown or Tupac violation right
away violation it would be any way
around though you know I mean in in the
via telling you that you know where they
tell a Pookie and Snoopy and Sheneneh on
the street corner I mean like you can't
be with your cousin you can't be reality
of that is that is total control like
when he did that Willie it disgusted
somebody how did that piece of dirt do
that yeah they though they should all
know they play since reconstruction
mm-hmm and I don't mean to say like that
but that's just how they list it it's
just it's a shame that I have to say
that yeah it's a shame that I know how
they think
yeah well I mean it goes back yeah I
mean that's a form of self hate the fact
that I love the way someone thinks about
me and I think about that mm-hmm
was it poisons your arraignment but
Maurice the same judge they gave me mill
those two to four years for popping a
wheelie
also grab this you know lesser known
person named Maurice he's a janitor yeah
he's a janitor he had two kids you know
especially
kids right he's with the baby's mom he's
going to work everyday but you know
those fees and fines pile up and you
have to try to pay him off well he got a
$1,900 and fortnight 1914 dollars of
unpaid fine yeah
she gave him two years in prison for
being too poor to pay nineteen hundred
dollars since a and so it was the same
judge judge Brinkley the same terrible
judge so Meek Mill jumped in and Michael
Rubin 76ers jumped in and we got him out
and but it just goes to show you have
bad judges but you also have bad laws
yeah if you can change the laws the
judges can't do anything but as long as
you leave those bad laws on the book a
bad judge will find that bad law and
abuse it so we're now in Pennsylvania
trying to change the law so we've got a
bill called 1555 in the house bipartisan
we've got a representative Harris and
representative jell-o's here he's black
she's white he's a Democrat she's a
Republican but they're working together
to try and change some of these unjust
probation laws so people don't listen if
you're on probation or parole and you're
out there committing new crimes that's
different
well if you're just talking to your
homeboy or you're 15 minutes late for a
probation meeting or your aunt is sick
and you go to check on her in the
so-called wrong neighborhood you're not
selling drugs over there you just
checking on your you shouldn't go to a
prison you understand you send somebody
to prison you're just gonna see you for
three months hold on a second three
months three months lock the door here
in Clinton for three months and see how
you feel and you had an apartment pretty
much later that apartment is gone you
had a little job three months later that
job is gone your children three months
later they're in foster care so why do
you think that is I think it's because
the whole way that the prison industrial
complex mass incarceration is built is
built off of poor people black people
and brown people that nobody cares about
if they listen I went to Yale not that
please I want to I saw more kids doing
drugs at Yale then I ever saw doing
drugs in a housing project but none of
them went to prison nobody even
call the police if they got caught they
went to rehab they didn't go to prison
the cop cars would drive past Yale with
the lights flashing past skullenbones
past all these people do these drugs to
go the housing project and put them in
prison for a little bit even kill them
or worse and so you can't tell me you
can't I'm hard to fool you can't tell me
that we don't know what to do with young
people involved with drugs because if
you're rich you going to rehab or Europe
and you come back in your life is fine
if you're poor black or brown you go to
prison so we got all these nonviolent
drug offenders that nobody wants to hire
but hold on a second show me the person
who's not a nonviolent drug offender
most people know I'm you know I can say
I've never been one but most people at
some point in their life
17 18 24 last weekend were nonviolent
drug offenders but they're in society
they're at the Country Club they're at
the Yacht Club they're golfing so
they're okay but they won't hire you
because you're not because all I'm
saying is it you ask why I think because
we have dehumanized I was just fade out
saying this and you think you take it
listen I was reading them don't look at
him off a slave documentary it wasn't
really safe it's a black duck to me
about um black people in the show during
slavery slave period how they wrote so
Ellison so nicely how useful the slavers
and the blacks are so strong and useful
to me and they're sort of slave and
reconstruction they talked about how
lazy they were and so they changed they
kept that perspective on the world and
everybody when you see we expect to see
a black man shot in the street this is
normal to us it's not shocking it's not
resounding whoa seeing that no this is
what we're supposed to see a [ __ ] get
being a black woman get shot in the face
of some cop beating this black woman
we're not supposed to get shocked at
that that's that's why we show it every
day see even yourself you see so much
you almost become numb to you expect
that to happen when it becomes shocking
then it becomes where people care mm-hmm
I remember when being back during the
black lives matter first jumped off and
you thought
13 and they would show the videos and
everybody would go crazy and stuff like
that now but I'm looking on my Instagram
if I see one of those videos almost go
past it because it's just I've seen it
too many times it's like it's just too
hard and you don't know what to do and I
know if I feel that way a lot of people
feel that way it's become desensitizing
and it begins so we have to participate
in the normalization march but this will
be a custom tool anyway they killed
another black person a rape but we're
accustomed to that you know that's just
what we're accustomed to in the black
community yeah well let me know the
positive part is that people at least
are starting to realize that you know
this incarceration industry that's what
I guess an incarceration industry
trafficking and human bodies yeah so
once we get them out of prison what do
we keep them on parole then probation
how do you work that fit so how do you
do in a guy's already spent 20 years in
jail how do you how do you civilize him
well I'm you got supplies Society first
so we don't put people in prison for
that long for minor stuff and I know but
listen
death could be very deadly though that
may take a minute they can get out now
but when they get out now now we have
uncivilized people excuse me I think I
don't know it doesn't matter what I
think but my my way of thinking if I ran
a civilization right that people that
come out of prison have to be in a
program to get civilized in society they
can't get Doremon society ever gotten
pretty 20 years fighting for the a
stabbing and cutting people and
sometimes getting [ __ ] but next he
still fight and now he's a savage I go
Dolman society and somebody talked to
him a certain way and and he slept he
blows up luckily you know we passed the
first step back yeah last year and they
get 7,000 people have come home there
was one who do did wrong and and
actually went up now he's being charged
with having kill somebody so you you're
correct it does happen but there's six
thousand 999 who did it who did come
home and who have done a good job so I
think a lot has to do with when people
are in prison what are we doing and a
lot at one person since the big impact
yeah that's a great big impact in 699
they did good
yeah so that's what we have to like to
make sure to tell the stories and lift
up the stories of the ones who are doing
well also one of those powerful things
is more people are going behind the bars
now to do literacy programs so talk to
women who are mothers behind bars
whatever and when they get behind there
they're like what the hell are we
spending taxpayer money creating this
much pain and suffering and that started
having impact but how do you how do you
stop them from being at what's the word
I'm looking for
stereotype to that page toughly addicted
to it I'm addicted to food I mean when I
used to get locked up I first got locked
up in sports and I'm 12 years old I'm
scared to death because I hear what they
do the people in sports it but I'm on
the streets will always keep the wild
kids I'm on the street I'm a ghetto kid
I've never been arrested I've been
arrested my number one that man locked
up before and so I'm scared I'm going
back here out everything they stab
people ability I'm scared to death as
soon as I get in there and they prove me
to the child time for breakfast they
bring me in and it's dirty Mike yogurt
all my friends was in there oh-ho I'm
not worried someone I got 200 guys right
here oh my friend those guys from my
hand got somebody we know on the streets
from robbing houses and they run the FIR
they run the place matter of fact I
don't want to go home them I want to
stay here Wow why cuz they've all my
comrades in here this is my family I
gotta go home in a stinking apartment of
[ __ ] rats and roaches
no food [ __ ] that three hots and a cot
fighting stabbing ho this is what I live
for
I don't want to go back home there's
nothing if I go back home I go get
someone and get back in here well you
know for me imagine that for 20 years
yeah I mean for me you know I'm uh
that's one day yes I see my friend in
this home I'm happy
did I am when I'm home I'm happy here
they're gonna stab somebody they're
gonna fight for me I worry about nobody
hurting me this is home you know our
lives are so different because you know
I grew up in the rules in the rural
South
my father was born in 1944
so segregation and poverty basically
what you would call a shotgun Shack they
didn't call it a Shack but it was a
shotgun house where each room is behind
the next room so you could fire a
shotgun through the front door and hit
everybody in the house so that's how
narrow the little property was that they
had and he joined the military to get
out of poverty put himself through
college but it's little brother through
college put a custom through college
married the college president's daughter
my mother because my dad had it like
that he was there he knew what he was
doing and so I was a total nerd like he
he would open up the refrigerator door
like I complain about anything do you
see this refrigerator there's always
been food in this refrigerator has
always been put what do you talk about
I'm like you know that's not that
impressive to me sorry like so I missed
that whole experience and I wind up my
father died they put the picture they
put him on the general program was him
standing in front of Yale Law School
with his fists in the air you know we
did it you know and so I'm like one
generation removed from all the stuff
that he went through but I was sitting
listening him him my uncles and that
sort of stuff talking about that stuff I
mean for me I feel guilty I almost feel
as a black man like I just never like
survivor's guilt I'm like why me mmm so
many guys were smarter than me I said
the same thing all the time to my worth
it and smarter than me got more power
than me more money than me has a bigger
family connection everybody respect them
you know me and they didn't make it
right and I always say is I'm is to
finally got it hmm you know I mean we
can't explain it but we know it yeah we
know we're different yeah and it's a
it's a I don't know it's a weird feeling
you know I go into prisons a lot just
because I'm a lawyer I'm trying to help
people and I just see all these brothers
and they're brilliant a strong
better-looking you know mean like
everything they have everything above
over me I mean if I had to compete with
these guys I would be their intern you
don't I mean I would
I'd have to work for these guys but
they've slept up all these black men and
put them all out of competition so then
I go in there and I come home and I'm
like I mean I just feel that's why I
fight so hard because I'm like these
these guys deserve a shot if these guys
had a shot they'd be running everything
because they're that stronger that's
smart Wow you get the you know you don't
believe it either this this is
interesting
well you're pretty smart listen um you
can't you have nothing to do with that
you know this is survival of the fittest
hmm
they look better than us they perform
better than us and all the praise be to
Allah but they're not hmm
it's an illusion where the survivors is
where the strongest their survival those
fittest and if you don't look at it like
that you strongly mistaken you think you
went all those schools by accident you
know me you were designed to do that
your father won do you think that was by
accident or design to do that my mother
was I'm father was there were street
workers they had me yeah my brother's a
doctor to an emergency in LA right but
listen no David's the street people and
they had me probably because they were
horny and look what look what I've been
all over the world the craft the colored
people I've touched you crazy and
touched me mm-hm
and it's just um it's just not by
accident because I had a low self-esteem
but still my megalomania I think I'm so
special you know but no one can see him
no one can see the things that I crave
about myself like I'm a I'm a piece of
[ __ ] someone else say that it's a fight
right away
because I don't think that but sometimes
I think I need to be checked because my
head is too big I think too much of
myself I don't think nobody could check
me but me yeah I I watched the you know
a couple documentaries about you which
you know I have on my laptop and but I
want to be inspired or Challenger
whatever I'll watch you
really yeah yeah man the things that
you've said that you've done you know
cus D'Amato and and how like you bad
Mohammed I leave when you're a kid like
all these different things I was in the
fourth school
yeah I know you're all think of me but
you know as a you know as a black man
watching the things that you've done and
things that you've been through your ups
and your downs you know your good
decisions your bad decisions or whatever
it does provide a road map because I
mean you're everything you do is so
extreme I mean it's just like the king
the biggest chip it ever like knocking
people out or whatever then like you
don't have noise problems and so you can
learn from your whole art but I think
you know from me I was a nerd I didn't
get any trouble cuz my dad and I was
just like scared of my dad and I don't
know what to do at this point I'm 51 I
work for President Obama I work for
Prince I was a grassroots outsider young
radical militant that became a White
House insider targeted by the media
right-wing media now I'm a part of the
media you know when I went to public
schools in the rural South I went to a
fancy I believe so I've kind of done 360
I've been so I'm hard to fool I've seen
so I've seen all these different points
and parts but after that I mean you
don't know what to do I mean I don't
know if you figure out that do something
on this podcast whatever but you can go
through so many things in life that you
don't really know what you know what you
do you know I don't know if you do it
that would but you may maybe you can
give on your needs you can do it and you
can show gratitude and thank God for all
the blessings that you got thank him for
your beautiful side yeah your hands your
feet you touch your beautiful children
you're experiencing life gratitude
gratitude then triples your blessings I
was such a selfish self-centered person
and I'm still that within this time but
I'm just very grateful and I have a lot
of gratitude but you as I saw you with
your with your wife that was amazing
you like y'all like you like touching
her hand and like doing all super sweet
stuff cuz I'm my wife is um I know who
and even see my rock my wife is much my
solar system when I my wife on my favish
I have no respect for women
nobody yeah my my my wife makes me out
makes me know that my man makes me
remember I'm a man and I'm not an animal
huh excuse me how does she do yes
existence the knee in this effort hmm
just didn't e in this over isn't being
in close to her now thought that hell
it's crazy like you know there's these
little tiny gestures like nothing's
really going on on sudden I look over
and you like just like touched her hand
or you like leaned over toward or
whatever does it put your head on our
shoulder I'm like it's like the most
fearsome no it's just different you know
I know what my man my wife has been
married for 10 years I know my wife
since she was 18
yeah and so we have a we have
interesting relationship and during my
relationship my prayers are free and
many times and I still want to do that
anymore you know I don't know I don't
say enlighten put up I've learned a few
things over the years and I don't want
to be the cause of her pain anymore
god is good well he's he's good but it
looks bad - he's always good it's
awesome it is awesome it's been awesome
to be here with you might also not be
with you man you know to watch your
growth and your evolution over the last
couple of years it's amazing dude I
guess meant um I know that I know this I
know human beings and I'm meant to be
humble they meant to be humbled you know
we have to we have to learn to be humble
hmm you know because um we have to know
that you know sometimes when we look at
ask me and my wife one day we were
watching my son play his baseball game
we're sitting down as a paper look at
his hands and all these answer and it's
about the time to see them where they
die so by now they've done everything
within the summer they've done
everything within two months whatever
summer is then we can do in a lifetime
hmm right and then I said you know that
baby not that wonder this
just like we're watching I wonder who's
watching us so ever think I might have
to be watching us like you watching me
then because we're when we're great but
we're not that significant yes if all
those ants died the world would die of
all the birth of all the trees that the
world would die if all of us died the
world would flourish so we're not that
hot [ __ ]
you know we're not really hot [ __ ] I
look at my ego and I wish I could shoot
myself in the head since I'm acting so
many great things and I'm a god in all
this [ __ ] and then I have to go and pick
my son's a basketball game well then
you've got I mean you you know man I I
don't I think you're right on your
destiny path what can we do I don't
think you do it I mean this is important
work you're doing manage at that and and
you have cultivated a very significant
presence in the media I believe that and
I think that the work you're doing right
now is is invaluable and you know I
think you know exactly what you're doing
dude
you know I tell you I am I'm getting
closer to God again mmm you know part of
what I think happened you know when
you're african-american man you're
Democrat and you decide you're gonna
work with Donald Trump can we talk about
that yeah pass the bill you go through a
lot yeah I'm sure that I felt like we
were in a you know a dilemma you know a
no-win situation either we just because
Republican would start to move in a
better direction on criminal justice you
know Rick Perry in Texas weirdly yeah
but listen from their point of view now
from our point of people from their
point of view they don't want to see a
big failed government bureaucracy eating
up taxpayer money making stuff worse
sure some of them are Christians they
don't want to do see no redemption some
of them are Liberty
I want to see liberties being till
they've not for our racial justice right
look at their own reasons sure they had
come around and then Trump comes in and
Trump was like law and order and you
know and was pushing the Republicans in
the wrong direction again and I had to
make a decision Democrats aren't as a
courageous when they feel like the
Republicans are gonna come after him and
call him soft on crime and that kind of
thing and so the key to Democrats being
strong as Republicans being strong the
key Republicans being strong as Trump
being strong so if I want I gotta go
deal with Trump yeah and or I could just
say well I cared about black people
under every other president I cared
about people in prison under Obama I was
in White House every week under Obama
big and let people out we gotta have
criminal justice and now this new
president comes in I'm nowhere to be
found
right so did I really care what was the
ego was it career so I got to go in
there and I got a deal with the guy and
you know front frankly he shocked a lot
of people he signed a bill that's led
out a bunch of people he's done way more
than people thought but man that was a
tough process because you know people
say oh you're giving him a win you're
giving Trump a victory but it's a
dilemma right if I can keep denying him
a victory but I'm also not all these
people in prison a victory yeah I can
give these people in prison a victory
but I'm giving him a victory well I
would rather for the people who I know
don't have a voice to be able to come
home and see their kids said okay he was
in the White House thing when I come
home to their Mama's house but man I
don't I went through a lot people that I
have respect and love say I was a
sellout Uncle Tom a [ __ ] a traitor you
told me yes still talking like that in
the 21st century
hey look at Kundun well first of all we
didn't hear enough of this in the media
William hear enough about this in the
media about the victory yes yes the
first step back victory you're the first
step back yeah no I mean it was think
about it now December 22nd I believe it
was maybe December 21st Trump signs the
first-step Act which the New York Times
says is most of substantial breakthrough
in criminal justice in a generation yes
it may where women
and be shackled anymore in federal
prisons when they're pregnant it made it
where people have to be held closer to
their families that made it we're a half
the federal prisoner to have people in
federal prison can earn their way home
sooner by doing a bunch of good stuff
programs and stuff a hundred percent can
come home sooner they just stay out of
trouble and 7,000 people got chance to
come home so that's a pretty big deal
and but do if you're the liberal media
do you want to give Trump that big
victory right probably is not gonna show
that [ __ ] they showed they showed it for
a minute but you know then the next day
I think the government shut down their
offer to other issues and if you're and
if you're the Conservatives you know you
kind of like it but yeah agent in a way
yeah and so you wind up with this with
nobody knows what to do it doesn't fit
the narrative that's what people write
that's what people don't want to involve
the religion because religion is like
this if you don't have the other
ideology that we have I won't change the
ideology you're going to hell that's
basically all religion the Christian
that's all religions you don't follow us
you're pretty min you're wrong you're
wrong
yeah yeah so it's only well it wound up
being so politics are like that if you
don't go with this way you're wrong yeah
but I'll tell you what
now I'm a lot closer to God well that
happens when you get in your fifties
because you close to your mortality
you know there's any moment you know um
that's like when we did the total you
know this just it's no it's gonna be
over soon not possibly win go see
another 50 right 2030 so you have to
prepare ourself for death we do it
without anything is unconsciously we
prepare for death that's what happens
when we start preparing for I def first
moment we born without unconsciously
knowing we stop the pan for it oh he
ready huh
I do you feel ready absolutely I think I
was born I think I was living too long
oh they anybody's with that why you say
that it's just um what are we here for
that's our purpose
you know we a purpose to die and go to
another place and some time and some of
us in
difficulties and handling that stage of
life we kill myself before with our time
because it's frightening about dying but
sometimes the thought of living life
thinking's my vine is too much mm-hmm so
you say this that's what I said in one
stage God made me I'm I wasn't doing
anything
no one asked to be here I was made and
now some and I gotta worry about dying
and then as I got older I realized life
was glorious we need the worst of life
is glorious I think death have to be
glorious as well as life because of -
how do they not be as it does not be
glorious and life is glorious life is
glorious if you're homeless or a beggar
if it's been hell life is there's
nothing there's nothing deep yeah I am I
don't know me I look at my kids now and
I got 15 year old boys tall as me and
super like you were talking about you
know how your kids are like really smart
and doing all kind of good stuff like I
got my older boy is um like a 4.0 and
taking physics and Mandarin and he's
like a soccer player and also so and
yeah I watched him and but you know why
he's living totally different life and I
lived when I was growing up was I wasn't
good in school and I wasn't a good
athlete so about watch this guy and I'm
like you know someday I'm not gonna be
here and he's gonna talk about who his
dad was mmm you know life just goes on
yeah and you know hopefully you know
he'll do well and he's little brothers
11 Oakley he'll do well but yeah it does
mean it's crazy
also I'm can III have nothing left to
prove for myself in terms of hmm to be
able to walk into the Trump White House
and come out with a victory for our
people even though it wasn't seen even
though it was recognized even though I
was criticized I know what we did that's
so huge and so you you know and so I
don't for me I'm sorry I'm thinking
about ways these next 5 10 20 30 years
going to be and I agree with you you
know gratitude is important but I just
it
I'm at a crossroads what are you
grateful for right now
alright well my kids you know my boys
are like amazing I mean the you my
little boy is emotional and difficult
and creative kind of like me and then
the big boy is like super like smart and
pretty well discipline this was a poor
teenager I like his mom and it's like a
chance to watch these like smaller
versions of us you know what I mean
going through the stuff that they go
through and I'm thinking let's listen
man I mean to get a chance to work the
Reform Alliance is amazing yeah I got to
sit in rooms of like you know
billionaires who care about people
behind bars
look screw and you just lay and they're
not they not half steppin they're not
messing around they're like we got to do
something most people don't know that
there are people at high places they
care hey you ever think about you why
you do this why you you know commercial
break today what do you mean no why do
you why do you what do you do what you
do why are you interested in this why do
you care about [ __ ] prison
mm-hmm that's all somebody some dad
daughter Mike died you know even when I
was a child I just had a lot of feelings
empathy like I live we live in the
country gravel road no you know we had
like a septic tank you know and no
streetlights and stuff like that so at
night you can see everything because
there's no streetlights or whatever but
also as a lot of animals so you know you
see dead you see death you know your
little kid you're looking out the window
and all sudden it's like there's like a
dead dog or a dead frog or a dead deer
or whatever is like just smashed up on
side and my parents got to the point
they wouldn't let me look out the window
because I'd be crying for like a day or
something like dog that I saw
and you know why why whatever so I was
always been really sensitive and you're
an empath yeah and so and then yeah my
dad was tough you know and I wasn't and
so that was an issue in the house he was
afraid that I was gay or whatever he's
afraid of but you know he's this tough
kid grew up in the you know you know not
even the hood like like really poor and
it was a military and so he's this big
tough he'd been a cop in the military
and this type of thing and I think this
like little kid that cries all the time
and like yeah so it was like an issue in
the house and and so I would read comic
books and stuff and I was read about
these great heroes who you know they
were I could nerd you know like Clark
Kent or Peter Parker but and they would
like you know become a hero and I just
think that imprinted on my brain that I
wanted to go out help people I don't
know why there's no there's no there's
no one thing that happened I just knew
from a very small age I wanted to help
people and also suddenly I looked up I'm
like 6 1 you know almost 200 pounds I
was like this big like all through high
school even into college like a little
scarecrow with big glasses you know
getting picked on and then all sudden
I'm not and I felt like I could do
something but people have asked me a lot
of times I don't I don't have a good
answer except to know that I hate
bullies
I hate when somebody has power and
abuses it I hate to see anybody being
mistreated and it doesn't feel like a
choice to me it's just like almost like
an automatic reaction trying to do
something and so I've just spent my
whole life fighting for really for other
people maybe for my own glory and stuff
but at the same time I know if I was
just after the glory I'd be a lot more
famous like I'm only just famous enough
to be able to fight my fight you know I
don't want it that's what you think
yeah it's all from your perception yes
sir what do you think I think you're
more famous than you think you are yeah
thank you it is too bad think you're
more famous than you think you are but
you don't think you're that thing that's
really weird
well I mean I work with like Anderson
Cooper and Jay Z like these guys are
like legends
at your level what did you just say what
did you say you say okay would you fix I
said I work with let's go that's it you
don't work with the militia they're
equal they may not think that mmm but
why were they talking to you hmm
why are you talking to them why are you
talking to me I'm really happy to be
talking to you I've seen you talk to all
those big shots whatever insecurities I
have I don't have no more can I talk to
you to just make those big shots did
you're the biggest Big Shot they out
there but that's that's that's who the
most insecure people in the world the
most powerful ones remember that they
say whatever you know how could you not
be insecure cuz you secure the position
that you're in you're in position to
lose that position you can never be
secured in our position
okay there's always somebody gunning for
it true so how can you be secured when
someone's gunning for you it's not no
that's not a secure position abiy
yeah like a uneasy where's the where's
the crown or whatever there's a crown
spear stuff yeah yeah man yeah y'all
y'all know podcast a lot more difficult
wait can we think about what do you ever
think about who's the first you whatever
the first Minto this man is 4.4 billion
years old right Lucy so 4.4 million
years where was the first year who you
think he would think you're Asian you
think you were white you think you're
African what do you think you were goli
what do you think you were the first you
say 4.4 million years ago the first male
your sperm what do you think what do you
think you would really think you had I
mean if they after the Africa but then
they found that there's a country under
Turkey that's 9,000 years old now they
gotta rewrite history
what do we know how do you rewrite
history when you find something uh
a problem like that no I don't know
anything we know if somebody told you
need not old you you know you know
you're a 51 because do you see the age
of 51 do you see the said I'm 53 so I'm
53 he said I was born in 1966 ad so
that's when I was born I didn't get no
information from nowhere I didn't do no
research the research I did find out
that this guy told me how old that was
so I'm gonna know anything about myself
that what I do know that I went to
prison I did this I became chair my work
here I do this definite but that's what
I know but after that I don't know
anything about nothing about me I don't
know if I'm from another planet a plant
here I don't know I don't know anything
what do you know less than I thought you
know I mean I know anybody's trying to
figure out the world what's the key
what's the magic key and somebody told
me especially for black people said the
answers so simple but for black people
who have to be complicated have to be
real complex to be the answer mm-hmm if
it's right in front of you it can't be
the answer the answer to everything is
really so easy well yes because it's so
easy we can never figure it out so we
still want to lecture we'll have to be
some apex and to let you stuff that we
can't pronounce like Nietzsche or [ __ ]
are you yeah yeah man I am I'm glad I'm
glad to meet you guys I mean that I
think you're doing something uh would
you write them I wrote down bipartisan
because I want to make sure to
underscore that Republicans are doing
some good things mmm I feel like you
know it's so polarized that um you know
we we almost don't want to give the
other side credit when they're right
yeah now look when they're wrong and
listen this is a lot of stuff we just
not gonna agree about and that's in a
democracy you will you disagree you're
supposed to fight and democracy you're
not supposed to agree dictatorship you
have to agree democracy means you can
have your opinion you can have yours you
can have yours but when we disagree
we're supposed to fight but where we do
agree we're supposed to work together
and we stop doing that so I always try
to remind myself
point out that out and then I brought
down my son hmm just want to make sure
to give him some credit I can name by I
work with a dictator I don't think they
should ever be a dictator I should think
that should be illegal agree no one
should be a dictator well in our country
it is illegal but still we have well
still listen Napoleon said this to his
mother there are always be kings even if
they go by different names and that's
what it is
yeah Trump is running this country like
he's a king yeah and that's just what it
is he feels like a king you know and
people who treats him like a king so he
lives like a king
and people love it everybody wants to be
a king in his sick mind you know well
he's um anybody think they're king in
their own world believe it or not you
know I mean even though my wife is the
boss of my house I believe I'm a king I
will leave on the king
Oh have the title yeah that's a great
quote by Napoleon then what do you see I
mean I know criminal justice reform is
going to be huge in this coming election
they're letting out damaged people well
but I I do see it differently because
yes there are some people who come home
you know who've had challenges but
usually my experience has been the
people who bloom enjoy people were
coming home they really want to land on
their feet and do well and we've got to
do a better job of give the place from
Brown the book ok yeah and this is what
I know what is it they call the return
rate receive the rate what a very nice
yeah from Brownsville Brooklyn man it
must be 80 percent if not more everybody
I know that's been locked up it's been
repeat offenders me all my friends
they're all in jail now our dead are
strung out on drugs very fewer than my
feet so you're one so you just saying
but you saying that we need to make sure
that there's a program when they come
home they can land on their feet you're
not saying leave them in there forever
you're saying when they come home your
program
I mean I must indeed I love this
Trombley because it helped me is know it
helps yeah and what what yeah yeah Oh
Graham yeah what you like what types of
things like an Outlook program you have
to go before you find the job you have
to get a skill for the job you have to
be able to they have almost like
hospitality skills take care of yourself
in the workplace I think we should spend
a lot more time working I think we
should put a lot along with workers you
know you came out of prison talking to
people crazy now you got to go on the
workplace what did you say you have to
be very careful after talking to someone
what you say to somebody that did 20 is
improvement it's all about respecting
how they talk to it's just a different
world yeah yeah you can't say [ __ ] off
all right dude yeah it's just to the
network biggest disrespect he told me to
[ __ ] off
right you know you got to change that
mindset before we get in the workplace
yeah I think as much time and energy as
we spend building up these prisons with
locking people up you know 140,000
dollars per year per young person locked
up you could send two kids to use a
racket so crazy what I would say is now
take that same amount in or keep that
same energy put fewer people in make
sure when they come home they do have
those kind of programs and will be
alright
the problem is that we spend so much
time and energy damaging people and then
we don't want to spend any money when
they come home do these guys that we
imprison they're making these plates
they're making these things in these
prison the people who they're making a
fool they should make it possibility for
when these guys get out after making all
that money for our company they should
be able to be civilized a little proper
word to say rehabilitated trans
transform what if I call it sure this
man I know what they do behind the
awesome and I say bring I say I say
bring him home and keep that same energy
to make sure they come home there right
away that's right absolutely being a
Mamba was to go bring him home - yeah
let's go but what does it do that
--eline out of the cage after 20 years
and just let him go on
and population I like I said you and I
agree that the way people come home
should matter and we said for them the
moment somebody goes in and you know I
wish that few people were going we
should be thinking about that day they
come home and every single day should be
supported to look right now nobody makes
money when the people go home and do
well they make money when people come
what go and they come back return
customers and what we've got to do we
got to change the financial incentive I
want a warden to be rewarded I would say
listen of all these five six people if
they leave on Friday and they come back
on Monday with their best friends you're
fired
if they leave on Friday and they stay
gone for three years and and they've
been productive we should give you a
million dollars because you just saved
us so much money in other words you
should you should get a reward for every
person who leaves your prison and does a
good job now every day you're in my
prison
I'm God you I'm doing yoga with you
right I'm teaching you you don't mean
because everybody come back into my
pocket there's no financial incentive to
do a good job that's America I looked at
our few years ago I watched this um
program about students like you say in
Germany hmm
you're a young kid 16 15 [ __ ] school I
don't want to go to school right I want
to smoke weed not the police the
government takes you and we train you to
work on our BMWs and I'm a city bibs and
work with the everything you only gotta
go to school for three hours here you
gotta go to class occasionally but you
work on our computers and stuff gonna go
in the cars and so this guys we're gonna
rock concert now he has a job he doesn't
like school you don't my school would
give you a job here yeah give you enough
school so you can graduate from high
school and you keep your job here and
then you're not there cousin yeah
working right you don't like school you
playing hooky or I'll give God take care
you hey you do in Japan for instance in
Japan great stood the business you know
what there was those the radio companies
and stuff from Japan
Sonia Sonia yeah I see all those places
they make deals with the school if you
give me two hundred thousand good
workers I promise them jobs in America
you don't make is on you
yeah you're born if you don't do that
you're [ __ ] he's on you you [ __ ] up
yeah the government and the school
system work together yeah they're better
business and the government work
together in their live better ways if
you see if you see every kid is your kid
you have a totally different system than
if you say oh well those kids their kids
nobody says oh my kids on drugs give
them 17 years in prison there's nobody's
ever said that about their own kid but
your kid give them 50 years and so
that's you know that's that's a
spiritual crisis that's that's a you
know the humanizing the opposite see no
hope in us yeah and by it's not by our
government not saying hoping us we don't
see hope in ourselves you know me so
they don't see a better hope in life you
know me failure the death pit I don't
see better why have I got to go school
why I listen to my mother why I'm gonna
die anyway they killed my father they
killed my brother my mother survived
then how do you feel about the more act
marijuana opportunity reinvestment an
expungement act of 2019 look I'm all for
it look I'm a nerd I've never had a beer
I've never smoked good there's smoke
where what I've never seen I've never
had a sip of wine never no no so I can
say as a complete nerd anti-drug nerd
that I'm against the drug war because it
doesn't work and you it has never been
prosecuted like there's more drugs in a
country-club Yacht Club Ivy League
school asked me out how I know I know
I've been all those places way more
drugs in those contexts then in then on
a street corner in the hood so now that
they're making it legal marijuana every
single person who is convicted of that
it should just be wiped off their record
yeah and all the money coming in the tax
money should be gone going back to those
communities back to those individual
and helping them get on their feet and
otherwise it's just another situation
where black people created a market why
people come and exploit it mmm when we
did it it was illegal they do it now
it's legal and we did when we did rap
music in the street the cops came and
shut us down
yeah now the cops come to stop the
people from freaking and stores I'm
still in it yeah I mean yeah but I mean
I've seen it I've seen in my whole life
you know I got a chance to work with
prints I did all of his philanthropic
work for about six years but that like
yeah I'm stoked
he's a very interesting ya know I mean I
am he saved my life man because you know
when I worked for Obama I only worked
there for about six months and then the
right-wing media came after me because I
was like young militant and stuff and
they're bringing back all the stuff from
when I was younger so they're also
making up stuff have me some stuff about
healing the younger what did you do to
make them think you're a militant I was
a Marxist I was in suing cops I was
protesting everything I could I was
every issue I could find it was against
the system nationalist Marxist and her
kids in deist because I was pissed off I
was like man if you're in your early 20s
I mean we were same age I mean you know
I mean a week in the 80s you know else
when Public Enemy and Spike Lee and NWA
came out so they had put it in our mind
that we need to stand up for ourselves
then we get in the 90s we finally get
rid of Reagan and Bush we got Clinton
and Clinton's worse mmm and he dropping
all these terrible Bayonne bills against
us and and he has this brainwashed she
had Clinton has more black people
brainwashed in liquor man yeah yeah yeah
I mean all that all that whole sick
clique although look I appreciated Bill
Clinton more after he was president when
he was doing he doesn't get credit for
afterwards see when he was doing the
Clinton Global Initiative and raised
millions of dollars and helping people
around the world but when he was
president he was weak on affirmative
action weak on welfare a weak on
anything black weak on criminal justice
and so I was mad and I wasn't I didn't
and I felt like my parents lied to me
you know my dad had been in the military
and you know
liberty and justice for all and all this
type of stuff and I'm like I'm at this
law school and I can't and I can look
down this street to the University and
see kids buckwild who
gonna be senators and I can look down
this street in New Haven to housing
project and kids who are doing less bad
stuff who can all gonna be in prison
I don't think and so I'm like my dad
lied to me this whole system lied to me
so I was just I was on the left side of
Pluto
I was I was considered a left-wing
radical father didn't like he was just
told you estimation he was fed right
exactly I was just passing along but you
know so you know when I was in a so as a
look I was considered a left-wing
radical in the Bay Area you have to work
hard to be considered a left-wing
radical in San Francisco and Berkeley in
Oakland but that's what I was but that's
where that stuff came from the exactly
so I was in all of that in my 20s when I
got to my 30s I burned out because it
was just too many protests too many too
many funerals with you know community
kids and who I work with or work here at
about in caskets and grown people with
gray hair send up in the pews like the
opposite of how it's supposed to be and
we're just banging our heads against the
wall and I couldn't see how we could
make it different so I burned out and I
decided to try and do something more
positive for the community bringing jobs
and we had just passed all these solar
bills and stuff in California so I said
why don't we get these kids on the
street corner jobs putting up the solar
panels solar panels don't put themselves
up and these people ordering all these
solar panels and they've taken three
months six months nine months because
nobody knows how to put them up so I got
the city of Oakland to start a program
called the green jobs Corps to train
these kids to put up solar panels Nancy
Pelosi found out about it she had just
become Speaker of the House the first
time she said bring van Jones to
Washington DC I was a nobody as a local
activist to talk to all of my Democratic
Congress members about this idea George
W Bush then signs the bill called the
green Jobs Act to spread my little
program in Oakland all across the
country that's 2007-2008 I wrote a book
about it the book became a best-seller
people on Barack Obama's team read the
book 2009 I'm in the White House so I go
from being a frontline grassroots
activist in like a two-year period to
being in the White House so the when the
right-wing media figure I said wait I
was like good dis dude mr. F the police
mr. suin cops
mr. Z goes down with the system is now
in the white house no this is not gonna
work so then I so so I said so prayer
saved my life because when I left the
Obama White House he picked me up
all right so cool that's awesome what's
that mean I mean what you just told me
what's all that mean how do you proceed
that you can see that all from your hard
work do you think that because you work
hard no anything no no it's not what you
think do you think that because you were
crying and working on it felt like I
like all of a sudden I was like walking
down the street and I put my foot down
on what I thought was the asphalt and it
was like a magic carpet and it just took
off and all sudden I'm in places I've
never been I'm seeing people I would
never thought I would meet I don't know
I know this is not you in your 50s now
right mm-hmm wow that sure that's your
mission I figure out all this stuff why
is this [ __ ] going on it's not gonna
stop you guys figure it out what's going
I'm thinking that to it I'm thinking
this I came in here four years ago I'm
well they decided to make this shot that
this is a [ __ ] joke I would be an
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah then so um we get a
guest that's out a shaman I don't know
the Charmin that that found Jewish to me
I see him he's not no he doesn't appeal
with Jewish so he's Mexican right Jewish
too so I'm just checking my so he's
talking about this toll in the venom and
stuff what are you talking about let me
see I'm gonna cocaine well you can't do
right here so what kind of [ __ ] you
talking about you can't do that I mean
cease doing drop out folks this whatever
is right here and he likes to stand a
crack pipe he's like some toads in a
nice smoky because I'm [ __ ] I was
drugged a [ __ ] aficionado
that's smoke where he goes out and I die
and if die you know is the most profound
moment in my life there's nothing in my
life not even much it was ever been
nothing that profound that experience
I've seen or felt and um this one
particular time I just felt like I feel
all the pain that I caused everybody
that I've been experienced in my life
cause I felt the pain a million a night
it's just I thought I'm a tough guy
think I'm a bad [ __ ] I thought a
card of war and I [ __ ] disintegrated
in his presence I was nothing you know
and I guess I never looked at people the
same I treated them the same of sense
and then I was mr. Kosan that I've ever
felt to experience anything to finally
Carly
it was so overwhelmingly breathtaking
everybody has different experiences and
every time you do it at the different
it's not like you get prepared for it
they're always taking you somewhere else
um yeah I know I don't I feel I feel
that I have a calling on my life
hmm I feel that's where I wanted to give
him touch I want you to get in touch
with that back home why did you feel you
had that girl who gave you that calling
a job I had to see somebody I remember
being a child and I will always want to
go in the backyard at night and lie down
on my back and look up at the stars like
I said we didn't have street lights so
you can see Larry every star and I'd be
out there and my mom would I could see
her opening that they had a glass door
you know there's like a like a back door
and she'd be the Anthony because my name
is Anthony Anthony get in this house and
I'm praying mama branches you can pray
in your bed get in this house but it was
just something I just felt and I was
probably like six seven I just felt the
prayer
so god I felt that that was something I
was supposed to do I felt when I would
every when I was a child they would they
would show us some you know Bobby
Kennedy and dr. King and these guys and
you forget like now they've been dead
for so long it's like not that big of a
deal but if you're born in 68 that's a
year they were killed so when you're in
kindergarten that's just five years ago
now imagine if somebody killed Obama
right now a child that was born in that
year five years later they've never they
don't know so I remember this kid named
Patrick Carmody in my kindergarten class
asked my teacher Miss Brown who was
Bobby Kennedy and she started crying
like a baby and I never seen an adult
cry I didn't even really know that dogs
could cry you know because there was so
you stopped crying so and I was like
whoa and I asked my mom and she was
stumbling around words and stuff and I
just felt again that these guys died the
year I was born
Bobby Kennedy was trying to do something
positive dr. King was trying something
positive for somebody it felt like I was
supposed to take up their car but it's
not rational because other kids heard
the same thing Brett the same thing
didn't they didn't do what I'm doing so
all I can say is that my whole life I
never had to guess what I was going to
do I always knew I was gonna work for
justice help people you know write and
fight that was the two things I wanted
to do that was too nerdy to fight but in
my mind I was preparing so I feel like
there's a calling on my life I feel
almost now like I said I have nothing
else to prove I already I've gotten four
presents in a row to do something
positive that I believed in and the
world is a shambles and all the stuff is
happening else polarization I don't care
what the Republicans or Democrats think
I don't care what white or black thing I
just want that's why I'm stuck I there's
there's a there's a prayer that's trying
to come through me that I've got to get
myself completely cleaned out and and
enable the channel so I can really find
out what God wants for me to do going
forward okay yeah I can take that
you know there's nothing really rational
about following your destiny path
because you're just divinely guided by
spirit you know so I mean it makes total
sense to me man I was 12 years old I'm
here at 13 I met this old Italian guy
right he became my mentor and trainer
right when I first met him I was a
[ __ ] about Wow
so uh such a low self-esteem so he was
white I was really small the white
behind it was judges that the cops that
arrest me and I'm and um mmm
also I'm not kind of guy thinking about
robbing a house I'm [ __ ] a little
thief I'm sleazy I'm just devious and
all sudden this guy talks to me and I'm
I'm like a [ __ ] rat and next thing I
know one of my name's we mention when
Achilles then friend is a great how does
that happen you come from nothing then
you want to think yourself serious you
have an illusion of yourself that I'm
greater I'm somebody I don't know how
does that happen but it does that's
custom auto yeah really go out the best
in people
yeah yeah if your relationship with him
is just unbelievable and his love for
you and and the way that you kind of
saved him like yeah they only want to
fit something close and he was telling
people in 1982 that I have a 15 year old
kid is living that clearly champ mm-hmm
you do crazy I say to myself with this
guy when they come from house they get
tired you know he was 57 years old when
I was born
how do you think I have enough to meet
me and it teach me that a short period
of time I accomplished this yeah that
blows my life
yeah it's really honor to meet you man
oh good thank you
it's pleasant well the event it's really
it's a pleasure to have you here man
before we get out of here yes sir I want
to ask you a couple more your thoughts
on a couple more things
oh the Rodney Reed case who's minding me
Rodney Reed is a man on death row in
Texas right now sure wasn't that on
television
yes I'm seeing in something it's been
all over the news then they stopped
establish yes a new trial yeah so he's
getting a new trial I was just curious
your thoughts on that and you know I
there there are two camps around his
case in terms of trying to get some kind
of justice I was the candidate said
freedom and there's a camp that's it
give him a fair trial I wasn't I was in
the fair trial camp I don't know if he's
guilty or innocent I know that trial was
effed up and I don't care if you're you
know you know the Nazis got you know
trials the normal world trials like
right now at what you did you deserve a
fair trial otherwise you know weird not
who we're supposed to be so I'm glad
he's getting a new trial I have no idea
he's guilty or innocent I never took a
position on that
it's amazing know how you know we have
so many bad cases out there you know dr.
Phil for whatever reason left on this
dude's case and then suddenly we were
able to get something done but it's
always like that you know one of those
people prominent um Caucasian
citizens have to say something I'd like
to wait there mind
hey they could be right because he said
it standing like this you know he could
say the lion is the truth and I could
say the truth when that's questionable
yeah and so you know for me and a lot of
people in the criminal justice world
they resent the power of celebrity in
this thing
I don't my view of it is you know any
weapon you know whatever you know you
know David was picking up rocks with a
sling you know whatever you can can use
to free people sure using saw and I'm
actually glad that more celebrities
getting involved but I think we have to
be careful and be reasonable and you
know like I said a fair trial versus
free that's that's that [ __ ] I want I
want you to have confidence in me you
know a year later if some bad facts come
out no I would I listen to van he
and pretty guy it's no mystery man you
know we made mistakes I'm letting out
the wrong people too right sure you know
yeah
the a big guy member that got added back
in the 70s normal email in them got him
out of prison and stuff they wrote the
book what's the book they were Billy it
was both Jack Abbot and then he got out
in the restaurant and I guess the way
this is something he thought with
disrespect when he killed them you know
yeah I mean we remember those things but
you don't think this guy's guilty I'm
saying those things out there as well
yeah yeah I mean that's the thing is
like you get both sides of it oh yeah we
have all these people out here who've
never been to prison who were gonna
commit a crime for the first time right
now we don't say lock up all those
people just in case I couldn't commit a
crime but my view about it is that we do
have to be we have to we have to receive
responsibly because we don't want this
movement to be destroyed by reckless you
know decisions so with that case I'm
glad that he's getting a new trial
yeah yeah it's good now you think the
country that we live in I need to be
paestum a country that we live in
there's not ready for justice yet hmm
well we're gonna get him ready yeah I
want that's what I wanted to say there
was it that this um Tyson Rancher you
know how boxing can do to help you in
your cause gonna have some brothers that
you know I grew up with that I go visit
them prison up there and all this field
in New York and they definitely got a
couple life is bad it's just
drug-related crime no one got killed
nothing on the record and it's really uh
yes they growing old in there yeah well
I think you in my heart we need to let
him come home I mean the whatever
whatever we thought in the 80s and the
90s was going to be a positive locking
up all these people for all this time
it's not turn out to be positive at some
point you know if you have a child
and they make a bad decision you want
them to revisit that decision and do
better but the grown people don't do
that
you know the adults pass these laws the
adults built these prisons the adults
you know are the ones guarding all these
people and we know what's wrong and so
you know I'm I'm not gonna stop until
some stuff is just like I call it's like
we need to build a like an anti stupid
coalition like someone stuff is just
stupid like you think they're gonna do
to us an X that's what most African
Americans think what are they gonna do
to us next I see it differently and
here's what I say why you asked me about
why me I don't have any good answers
back and I can tell you this
all of these African people who were
brought over here 40 years ago and they
haven't brought that many of us over
here since so yo I'm like I'm a nice
generation American and I'm the first
one in my family born with all my rights
recognized by this government in 1968 to
think about that they stopped bringing
us here like kind of 50 years ago but
here we are and for all of our problems
and all of our pain all of our suffering
this community of people not only in
terms of the level of creativity and
music and art but politically we're
against every war black community we
rich black people vote like poor black
people you know taxes programs all that
type of stuff
we're like a saving grace in this
country and we as wild as we are toward
each other
collectively we bring a wisdom we bring
a grace we bring a beauty to this
country that I think it's going to be
the saving grace of this country and so
I believe that that's why we were
brought here I think if you just had
these people came over here is like
Cowboys killing people and stuff and
gave them a country this rich just for
them to run it would be one of the worst
things ever but we're here and we keep
challenging the conscience of America
from within and we keep saying but you
put on paper as liberty and justice for
all and you're not doing it you put on
paper America the Beautiful but we're
being ugly there's a there's something
of our suffering is redemptive because
we keep challenging this country to be
better and this country would not be a
democracy except for us it was a settler
colonial slave state at its founding and
they fought a civil war to turn it into
apartheid because we had a hundred years
it was segregation still it still won a
democracy it what a democracy until a
couple years for you and I were born
when dr. King and and Ellen Joe Baker
and all those people made it a democracy
so you know dr. King is like the final
founder in a way it took them 200 years
to even get to where we are now
and we were pushing the whole time
abolition and justice and labor and all
these things so for me I don't ask what
are they gonna do to us next I say well
how are we gonna continue to evolve our
capacity to be a saving grace in this
planet how do we keep our humanity how
do we can gather we continue to be who
we're supposed to be and I don't know if
we're gonna succeed or fail but I'm a
lot more I see us as the agent of
history I don't see us as the object the
victim I see us as the agent of history
and you know that's that's for me that's
my calling you know that's pretty
awesome too that's extremely awesome and
I go with by this I look at this
situation African Americans and now 2020
and I'm a mom 1895 that's um that's when
I'm Frederick Douglass was dying and he
said there's no hope in the black race
he died with no hope for the black
people and then you look at guys like
you myself and everybody he was one of
the greatest minds ever lived he was so
wrong no way the greatest mind my
greatest leaders he was so wrong that's
what I hope for the black we could at
bay et 95 he thought there was no hope
for us so just the way the laws were the
Jim Crow Becca it was just so oppressive
mm-hmm but you know we fought through
and just 40 million of us now like I
said they stopped bringing us over here
a long time ago so the people who
literally the same people but think
about the same people he was looking at
then there's no hope they didn't present
it exactly awesome stop that's why I
know nobody knows anything okay who you
are brilliant you are when you know when
the universe start to make their plans
it just happens this world is gonna be
okay it's as bad as we think global
warnings gonna take us out all this this
world has been here for a long time and
it's gonna be okay
else is gonna be like the rest of the
flatness around us dust yeah Mars we
don't know what's on there you know we
might have come from there and that's
what they're talking about
could be hey Sam
well I wanted to ask you about Colin
Kaepernick what's that with that guy he
look good at Miss practice I was
watching yeah yeah yeah
I wish you'd gone to the practice that
they set up for him yeah that's how I
feel I know that jay-z and and Desiree
and the folks at rock nation fought very
hard behind the scenes I'm represented
by rock nation they fought their side
caps agent agents don't know know it but
you know they were helping you're
helping this yeah like you know this all
these doing away I think they're too
hard on Jay they love cheese I think
they is too hard I think I feel the
green-eyed monster in this situation
when Jay Z's involved yeah I agree
no I I agree listen Jay Z's a
billionaire he doesn't even have to sit
down the NFL and do anything but yeah
there's gonna be announced as made in
terms of the amount of money that's
coming from the NFL to the hood for the
first time even beyond beyond what's
been done before and you know he fought
very hard behind the scenes to give
Colin Kaepernick his chance and as as
did the Masters I mean the masses are
are and weren't with Colin saying hey
let's brothers should be able to speak
his mind and go out there and play this
game but to me if I'm going for a job
interview and it's a nine o'clock on
this corner and I changed my mind and
say no I want to do my job interview at
8:30 or 10 o'clock on another building
yeah that gives them an excuse not to
give me the job yeah and that's my
problem
I just wish that he just just go Jamie
it's not for you it's for this for all
these children who are looking at you as
a hero and a czar as somebody who's like
the Muhammad Ali of our time right like
go and knock the dude out be Bahama
dolly go and throw the ball in they face
yeah and when you don't do that now they
have an excuse forever well we would
have if you now come on man
so that I just wish that he just gone
and done and how they listen to just
humble yourself for one second and doing
how they said do it show the whole world
now if they don't give you anything we
can march and protest and the whole
world will know that you were stolen it
was stolen from you because you were
there and you did it now it's always
gonna be a question mark he doesn't know
how to play the game yes I was gonna be
a question mark now he doesn't want to
play the game you'll make it really
complicated you know we all play the
guitar we all dances here yeah that's
what my son was was asking about the
thing is like well you know college
should be able to I said white people
can't tell you when the job interview is
that's not racism like no white man can
go to a white man and say I'm gonna tell
you you're gonna do my job interview
over here I said white people ain't even
out that much right you gotta show up
yeah that's a job interview when they
say even if you wait row that what do
you think I'm helpin us so that's not
racism at that point that's just that's
just how it works
I mean can you just go and then tell
them we got this job did you just tell
them when you know yeah white people
can't do that no so I appreciate that
yeah anyway
move in you're the man no [ __ ] man
thank you for coming here
I appreciate it may I appreciate the
opportunity and have me back and like I
said I'm I'm Lily at a spiritual
crossroads and I'm praying for God to
give me give me my next set of
directions and orders and you know this
has been powerful imagine I mean we just
met Mike so exactly that's our step yeah
I always love your perspective man yeah
his corporate media sucks I have to say
it's it's not it's not a public radio or
you know the stuff I love still why love
I love Sesame Street
I love hotel you know I love mr. Rogers
I love Electric Company because TV was
like to see Morgan Freeman electric
company
yeah but you think about it because TV
we're going up with like a wasteland of
like cartoon violence and cut Cowboys
shoot America and they had these couple
of shows it was all violent and crazy
and then they had a couple of shows they
said that we're gonna use television for
good yeah and that's what in my heart I
want to use TV for good and so I
appreciate seeing and they let in the
Van Jones show they call Sesame Street
for grown people I try to mow bring
people together they let me do the
redemption project where I was showing
people coming together who you know want
to commit a crime the other would have
been the victim we brought them together
incarceration incorporated podcast so
let me do so CNN keeps letting me do
positive stuff um but it's tough because
it's uh you know it is it's a very very
negative media environment right now and
we got a we got to keep we got to keep
our candle lit for good
we gotta keep our total it so we'll keep
doing it man amen thank you spreading
the truth
thank you brother so awesome got our
support and any way that we can support
you don't worry
hey listen what it's not time to fight I
call on all forces awesome people can do
where they can find you and which is
good yes listen a reformed Alliance calm
just you go there you can sign up you
can be a part of what we're doing I'm
proud to be a part of the cut 50
movement see you t-50 org is also a
great organization but the main thing is
in your own life if you can give a job
to somebody consider somebody who's
formerly incarcerated consider somebody
who's you know from a tough neighborhood
if you you know if you've got a school
you're running or program include people
just because somebody did something and
got caught that you probably did when
you were in college don't leave them out
love it very much
what do you think what the world needs
more now is love sweet love Amy yeah
Mike yes great show beautiful beautiful
episode hey everybody thank you so much
for listening to this special episode of
hot dogs I had my mother-in-law right
here because she came to see the Van
Jones
hi to the people out there mom it means
of people looking at you my love but
they got good genes in that Fame yeah
good genes good people awesome well
until next time everybody I'm Everett
Britain and I'm Mike Tyson we're out of
here
see ya peace Thank You van that looks
pretty awesome husband thank you very
much
definitely that the deepest interview
I've ever done
[Music]
[Music]